I was trying to describe to you how the Athenian democracy in its full form
after the reforms that were instituted by Pericles after the death of Effie
outis how that how that system worked.
And I described the what we would call the legislative branch and the much less
significant executive branch and now I'd like to turn to what we would call the
judicial branch.
Now this Athenian judicial system I think might seem even more strange to the
modern eye than the rest of the Constitution.
You start with this panel of six thousand jurors who enlisted to serve in the
courts each year on any given day.
The jurors who showed up to accept an assignment were assigned to specific
courts and to specific cases the usual size of a jury seems to have been five
hundred and one.
Although there were juries of from a small as 51 to as many as fifteen hundred
and one in depending on what the case was whether it was public or private and
also how important it was to avoid any possibility of bribery or partiality.
The Athenians evolved an astonishingly complicated system of assignments that
effectively prevented tampering.
That system is described in Aristotle's constitution of Athens.
I think it's chapter sixty one if any of you think that you have about a month
or two to spare.
Read that paragraph and tell me what the hell it means how it works is so
complicated and the point is that they wanted to be sure that it was just
impossible for anybody to know who was going to be on a particular jury panel
for a particular case so that if you wanted to bribe anybody you'd have to bribe
six thousand people and that might be mildly discouraging you might say that's
that's an honest bunch of people boy.
Well you don't devise such a complicated system if everybody isn't busily
thinking of a way to cheat.
It seems to me however they would have failed the system certainly was
foolproof.
I think the legal procedure was remarkably different from what takes place in a
modern American court.
The first surprise you would meet is the absence of any public prosecutor or
state's attorney.
In fact there are no lawyers at all.
Think of that.
Think of how happy that would make Shakespeare.
Complaints whether they were civil or criminal.
Public or private.
Large or small were registered and argued by private citizens plaintiff and
defendant sewer and sue each made his case in his own voice.
If not in his own language because anyone was free to hire a speechwriter to
help him prepare his case and that profession flourished in Athens although it
reached its peak only many years after the days of Pericles the greatest writers
of courtroom speeches that have been preserved and I believe they were preserved
because generations thought they were the very best speeches that were come from
the next century from the 4th century B.C..
Here's another surprise.
There is no judge the jury was everything.
No self respecting Athenian Democrat would allow some individual whatever his
qualifications to tell him what was relevant evidence and what was not or which
laws or which precedents apply from the Athenian point of view that would give
too much weight to learning and to expertise.
And it would also create the danger of corruption and undemocratic prejudice.
I mean if the judge you couldn't conceive conceal who the judge was going to be
as well as you could the jurors.
And so you could if he if there was a judge and he was important you might be
able to bribe him.
Indeed in our own system it is not unheard of that judges are bribed.
It's not even unheard of that they were unduly prejudiced in one direction or
another.
You've seen seniors would have none of that.
So it was up to the contestants in the case to cite the relevant laws and
precedents.
And it was up to the jurors to decide between the plaintiff and the defendant so
in fundamental matters of justice and fairness the Athenian Democrat put very
little faith in experts.
This was one of the most democratic aspects of this democratic constitution.
The assumption that all citizens had enough sense and enough of whatever else it
took to make the judgments that were so important in the courts in the courtroom
the plaintiff and defendant each had an opportunity to present his case also to
rebut his opponent.
To cite what was thought to be the relevant law.
To produce witnesses and then to sum up his case each.
Now here's another amazing thing from an American perspective.
Each case I'm sorry each phase in the case was limited to a specific amount of
time which was kept by an official using a water clock and no trial gets this
lasted more than a single day.
Finally the case went to the jury which of course received no charge or
instructions since there was no judge to tell them what they had to think about
and what possibilities were available.
The jury did not deliberate.
You didn't have fifteen and one fifteen hundred and one angry men
they just voted.
By secret ballot.
And a simple majority decided the issue if.
A penalty was called for and it was not one that was described by law.
And very few penalties were described by law.
The following procedure was used.
The plaintiff who had won the case proposed a penalty.
The defendant then had the opportunity to propose a different penalty.
The jury then again no deliberation just voted to choose one or the other but
they could not propose anything of their own.
No creative penalties were possible just one or the other of the ones proposed
by each side.
Normally this process led both sides.
If you think about it to suggest moderate penalties for the jury would be put
off by an unreasonable suggestion one way or another.
If the plaintiff asked for too heavy a penalty that would guarantee they would
take the other guy's penalty and vice versa critics of this system complain that
democracy made the Athenians litigious.
The system contained a device therefore well not therefore but as a matter of
fact in contradiction to that.
No let me back up.
Of course Athenians were litigious and knowing that they built in an element
meant to reduce the degree of unfounded unreasonable silly or just terrible
accusations
the system contained this device.
If the plaintiffs did not win a stated percentage of the jurors votes then he
was required to pay a considerable fine
in public prosecutions.
He paid it to the state in private past prosecutions he paid it to the
defendant.
And surely this must have served as a significant deterrent for frivolous
malevolent and merely adventurous suits.
Just think of how it would change our system if we had something like that.
If the way we do we do have a lot of some of it available in our own system.
It is possible for instance if somebody brings a suit against somebody else and
fails it is possible for the judge to decide that the defeated side must pay
court costs which is a form of a defense against the frivolous charges.
But it wasn't.
It isn't anything as thorough as the Athenian system which always had that
around.
So if you had a case that wasn't going to win many friends on the jury it was
going to cost you one way or another.
Well this Athenian system of justice had many flaws.
Obviously decisions could be quirky.
And unpredictable since they were unchecked by precedent.
Juries could be prejudiced and the jurors had no defense except their own
intelligence and knowledge against speakers who cited laws incorrectly and who
distorted history and we have speeches in law courts in which these guys are
making up laws that nobody ever heard of and that they are making arguments that
are terrible so that they did abuse this opportunity.
There's no question about it.
Speeches unhampered by rules of evidence and relevance and without the
discipline imposed by judges could be fanciful false and sophisticated.
There's one anecdote that is handed down about a famous Athenian.
After that I think gives you some clue about this.
Yeah.
This was listeners who lived at the end of the 5th century and into the 4th and
he was one of the greats successful speechwriters in Athens.
Well somebody came to him and said I'm involved in this lawsuit licious and I'd
like to pay you for writing a speech on my site which is fine.
He went home he wrote the speech.
He brought it to the man and said Here it is the guy read it.
He said listen this is terrific great speech.
I can't lose.
Thanks a million this just goes on a little while later.
This is here's a banging on his door.
It's the same guy he's in.
This Yes I read that speech again.
Was I wrong.
It's filled with terrible arguments contradictions.
There are holes in your logic that they can run trucks through.
And Lissy says Calm down my friend.
The jury will only hear this speech once
so of course all of these flaws were there.
Yet from a modern perspective I would argue that the Athenian system had a
number of attractions.
The American legal system and court procedures have been blamed for excessive
technicality verging on incomprehensible ability and for the central role of
lawyers and judges which give an enormous advantage to the rich who can afford
to pay the burgeoning costs of participating in the legal system the absence
typically of a sufficient deterrent to unfounded lawsuits has helped to crowd
court calendars time spent in jury selection which didn't take any time at all
of course in Athens and wrangling over legal technicalities stretches out still
further a process that has no time limit.
It is not uncommon for participants in a lawsuit to wait for many years before
coming to trial.
Sometimes the plaintiff has died before his case gets to court.
Not everyone is convinced that the gain in the scrupulous protection of the
participants rights in an increasingly complex code of legal procedure is worth
the resulting delay.
And some point to the principle that justice delayed is justice denied often in
our courts.
Decisions are made by judges on very remote difficult legal or procedural
grounds that are incomprehensible to the ordinary citizen.
As a result there is much criticism of judges and lawyers and a loss of faith in
general in the legal system for all its flaws.
I think the Athenian system was simple speedy open and very easily understood by
its citizens.
It did contain provisions aimed at producing moderate penalties and at deterring
unreasonable lawsuits it placed no barriers of legal technicalities or legal
experts between the citizens and their laws.
Counting as always on the common sense of the ordinary Athenian
now the Athenian democratic system as a whole brought to its height in the time
of Pericles has been harshly criticized through the ages.
Immediately by
contemporaries who were hostile to the democracy and through the centuries by
people who have looked at Athenian history as it was depicted by the surviving
authors and concluded harsh conclusions about democracy ancient rivals directed
most of their attacks against the idea of government by mass meaning and the
selection of public officials by allotment the Athenian renegade al-Sabah
pieties told a Spartan audience.
As for democracy nothing new can be said about it and acknowledged foolishness
Plato has Socrates make the same point more fully and seriously Socrates
observes that when it is a matter of building a house or a ship the Athenian
assembly listens only to experts.
If someone without expert qualifications tries to give advice in such things
even if he is very handsome and rich and noble they refuse to listen to.
Instead they laugh and hoot at him until either he is shouted down and withdraws
of his own accord.
Or the Sergeant at Arms drag him off or he is expelled by order of the president
so you just imagine that.
When you get up to speak in the Athenian assembly you better be ready for
anything
but when the discussion is about affairs of state says Socrates.
Anyone can get up to speak Carpenter Tinker cobbler passenger ship owner Rich
and poor noble and commoner and nobody rebukes him as they did in the earlier
case for trying to give advice when he has no knowledge and has not been taught
now in fact the Athenians did appreciate the importance of knowledge skill
talent and experience when they thought these things existed and could be used
in the public interest so they did not a lot but elected military officers.
Some treasurers naval architects.
And managers of the water supply.
These are essentially questions of life and death or of the financial security
of the state.
Apart from that they did not care much about expertise.
If they did not elect professors of political science or philosophers or lawyers
to govern and judge them it was because they were skeptical that there is a
useful expertise in these areas and that if it did exist it could safely and
profitably be employed for the public good.
It is not clear to me anyway that the experience of the last twenty five hundred
years has shown them to be wrong.
I don't know how many what percentage of the representatives and senators in our
Congress are lawyers by training but whatever that figure is it's far too large.
I think it's really extraordinary that we all sit still for that kind of thing
the kind of variety excuse me of profession that one can find in our society is
absolutely not to be seen in our government institutions.
Well the Athenians would never permit anything so undemocratic as that.
Secondly it is most unlikely that many fools or incompetents played a
significant part in public affairs.
Of course that's the flip side of rejecting expertise and experience.
You may end up with people who don't know what they're talking about in any
shape manner or form having influence.
Well you see seniors knew that and they were worried about it.
And I think that they did so perhaps that the possibility of idiots fools jerks
and other unworthy is
dominating the political decisions.
I don't think that it's clear that we are better off than they are in this
respect.
I offered my William Buckley once said he would rather be ruled governed by the
first forty whenever he said forty fifty people in the Boston telephone
directory than by the Harvard faculty.
I thought we could all we could all agree with that.
Maybe even the Yale faculty.
I think that.
It's we ought to think a little bit longer before we assume our system is the
only way one can think about conducting a democracy.
But to get at it.
How the Athenians cope with this problem.
This is the assembly itself.
Was a far less unwieldy or incompetent body than is generally assumed by its
critics and that you might ordinarily think would be the case if you've got five
six thousand people out there trying to make a decision.
Think of this if an Athenian citizen attended no more than half the minimum
number of sessions held each year he would hear twenty sets of debates by the
ablest people in the state.
Chiefly elected officials or those who formerly had held elective office the
leading politicians in all factions and a considerable number of experts on a
variety of subjects who would simply get up and express their views and these
were true debates in which it was not possible to hold two prepared remarks and
look at your.
What do they call these books that they use their policy books or whether
they were real debate and the speakers had to respond extemporaneously to
difficult questions and arguments from the opposition nor were they they
irresponsible displays.
But serious controversy is leading immediately to votes that had important
consequences for the orators and their audience.
Now if you assume that each attendant at the Assembly had been listening to such
discussions for an average of only ten years and many of them would have had a
much longer stretch think of it.
Think of it.
Such experiences alone must have fashioned a remarkable body of voters.
Probably I would argue more enlightened and sophisticated than any comparable
group in history.
Apart from that every year 500 Athenians served on the council where every day
they gained experience in the management of Athens affairs from the most trivial
to the most serious producing bills that served as the basis for the debates and
votes of the assembly.
So in any particular assembly thousands of those attending perhaps a majority of
them would have had that kind of training on the council in light of that
breadth of experience.
The notion that decisions were made by an ignorant multitude is simply not
persuasive.
I like to compare that situation with something that I think perhaps we can
understand in the 19th century when people went to a concert of what we call
classical music.
Almost everybody in the audience was a musician of some kind.
Was that before radio television recording systems if you wanted music you had
to play it.
And so people especially women but men too studied how to play various
instruments and they could say they could read music and they could understand
it in a way that only a participant can hardly anybody who goes to a concert
today is in that situation.
So Beethoven and Brahms and people like that.
Wrote their compositions and played there and the orchestras and so on played.
Those compositions to people who were in a certain sense almost experts in any
case very well-educated amateurs.
And it's.
That's the analogy I would suggest that we're talking about that the
professional politicians so to speak insofar as they're worrying in Athens were
dealing with people who didn't just come in off the street and didn't know
anything about it.
They were prepared by their life's experience to be a very very tough audience
indeed.
But that raises the question were debates in the assembly carried on by ordinary
citizens without the necessary special knowledge and capacity for informed
advice.
The evidence I think suggests not for there were impressive deterrents both
formal and informal that would make an inexperienced ill informed poorly
educated man reluctant to speak up in the Assembly or the council even
to begin with I would suggest another analogy for you.
For many many years I have attended meetings of faculties at great American
universities but I have seen is that very few and generally the same few are
bold enough to speak for or against some not very controversial policy argued in
a group of fewer than a hundred people not to mention those rare larger meetings
when subjects arousing passions are at issue.
Now the people we're talking about these faculty meetings have extraordinary
educations.
They are alleged to have unusual intellectual ability and they belong to a
profession where public speaking is part of the trade
the meetings are conducted in the decorum of established rules of order that
forbid interruptions and personal attack if a guy wants to say that man is a
goddamn liar.
Somebody will call him to account and say that was a violation of personal
privilege and he should cut it out.
That's not the way it happened in the Athenian assembly.
And yet even at these very very genteel faculty meetings I'm talking about those
who attend them speak very rarely if ever.
Why
why.
What is it that they terms.
I ask you.
For instance you you all know the answer but you won't speak up.
Why why are you afraid to answer that question.
You know the answer.
Thank you.
That's exactly the reason people really are afraid of that.
They're just afraid that even if nobody even tells them that they're stupid just
the way they react and they make them feel as though they are stupid.
This is a fantastic deterrent.
And if we don't understand that we will not understand the way the Athenian
assembly work because that was a made.
But of course you know perfectly well.
Their problem was much greater meetings of the Athenian assembly were not quiet
seemly occasions.
We should not forget what D.K.
chapel has said in Aristophanes play sitting there on the panics.
You say you threatened to shout.
To interrupt to abuse the speakers.
We shouldn't effect.
Forget Plato's report of how the Athenians laughed and hooted or shouted down
speakers who lack what they thought was the necessary expertise.
Now these informal deterrents alone I believe sharply limited the number of
speakers in the assembly but there was also a formal device that encouraged them
to take thought before they intervene and to be careful in what they said in
these debates.
On the next at sometime perhaps during the career of Pericles but certainly not
more than 15 years after his death the Athenians introduced a procedure called
the carafe a part of normal that had the effect of making the citizens in the
assembly the guardians of the constitution.
Any citizen could object to a proposal made in the Council or in the assembly
simply by asserting that it contradicted an existing law.
That assertion stopped action on the proposal or suspended its enactment if it
had already been passed the proposer was then taken before a popular court.
And if the jury decided against him his proposal was disallowed and he was fined
three findings that a person had done this deprived him of his rights as a
citizen.
The expectation of the Assembly and its procedures formal and informal.
Made it most unlikely that ignorance incompetence played a very significant role
in its deliberations of course.
There was some ignorant imbeciles who nothing will deter but that's true of our
system too.
And even graver charge has been leveled through the ages against the kind of
democracy promoted by Pericles.
It is said to be inherently unstable inviting faction and class warfare.
It is said to be careless of the rights of property and to result in the rule of
the poor.
These rather the poor who are the majority over the rich minority.
These arguments weighed very heavily in the thinking of the founding fathers of
the American Constitution who rejected democracy.
You need to be aware of that their notion of what democracy was was Athenian
democracy as described by its critics and they consciously and plainly rejected
democracy.
They thought something else.
They thought they were creating a popular Republic and by Republic they meant
something different from democracy.
Starting with the fuller democracy instituted by Effi Alves empirically in fact
we discover an almost unbroken orderly regime that lasted for one hundred and
forty years.
Twice it was interrupted by oligarchic episodes.
The first resulted from a coup de tah in the midst of a long and difficult war.
The government of that oligarchy lasted just four months.
The second was imposed by the Spartans and after they won the Peloponnesian War
that one lasted less than a year
on each occasion the full democracy was restored without turmoil without class
warfare without killings or exiles of revenge without confiscating the property
of anybody.
Through many years of hard warfare military defeat foreign occupation and
oligarchic agitation the Athenian democracy persisted and showed an restraint
and a moderation rarely equaled by any regime.
Now this behavior is all the more remarkable in light of the political and
constitutional conditions that prevailed in the proclaimed clean democracy and
thereafter.
Remember that the mass of Athenians were not faced with the power of what has
been called a military industrial complex.
They were not thwarted by the complexities of representative government by
checks and balances by the machinations of unscrupulous lobbyists.
Or manipulated by the irresistible deceptions of mass media
they had only to walk up to the pics on assembly day make speeches and vote.
In order to bring about the most radical social and economic changes they could
if they had wanted to.
They could have abolished debt which presumably would be something the poor
would favor.
They could institute confiscatory taxation of the rich in the to the advantage
of the poor.
The simple expropriation of the wealthy few.
All of these things they simply could have done nothing would have stopped them
but they never did.
Although political equality that is to say equality before the law that was a
fundamental principle of democracy but economic equality had no place in the
Athens of Pericles.
On the contrary the democracy he led defended the right of private property and
made no effort to change its unequal distributions.
The oath taken by jurors.
Each time that they sat on the jury included the following clause.
I will not allow private debts to be cancelled nor lands or houses belonging to
Athenian citizens to be redistributed.
In addition the Chief Magistrate each year swore.
That whatever anyone owns before I enter this office he will have and hold the
same until I leave it.
Athenians respect for property and their refusal to insist on economic equality
go a long way towards explaining why their democracy was so peaceful.
So stable and so durable.
But why were the majority of citizens so restrained and moderate part of the
answer lies in the relatively broad distribution of property in 5th century
Athens was by no means equal.
I use that.
I want to emphasize the word relatively compared to states that were
oligarchical or aristocratic
and also in its growing prosperity through the greater part of that time.
It's very hard to sustain any kind of a reasonable moderate regime in times that
are hard times in which there is great poverty.
So that was these was certainly among the reasons why Athens was so successful.
But there was always.
We should remember a group of fabulously wealthy citizens and also thousands who
were poor by any standard.
It certainly seems clear that at any time in this period the majority of
Athenian citizens were not rich enough to be whupped lights not rich enough even
to have those small family farms that supported your infant treatment.
So it's not as though there aren't a lot of poor people in the state.
The poorest.
Moreover those who lack the property to qualify as infantrymen with the very men
who rode the ships that brought Athens wealth and power and glory.
The last 30 years of the century.
Furthermore what terrible times of war plague impoverishment and defeat yet
either during or after the war.
Did the Athenian masses interfere in any way with private property or seek
economic leveling in the two ways that revolutionaries always wanted it.
Canceling debts and redistributing the land
in the power of clean democracy the Athenians some citizens demanded only
equality before the law.
I think that is the key principle to understand when you're thinking about
Athenian democracy.
Full political rights for all citizens and that is what separated the Athenian
democracy from oligarchies and aristocracies and other Greek states and the kind
of even chance that is provided by these two things equality before the law and
participation in the political process for all citizens
by these rules the Athenian was willing to abide in the face of the greatest
disasters and the greatest temptations.
It was this politically equal individualistic law abiding and tolerant
understanding of the democracy that Pericles had done so much to create and to
which he could appeal and point with pride confident that his fellow citizens
shared his views in their rational secular worldly approach to life in their
commitment to political freedom and to the autonomous importance of the
individual in a constitutional republican and democratic public life.
The Athenians of Pericles day were closer to the dominant ideas and values of
our own era than any culture that has appeared to the world since antiquity.
That is why prickly and apparently in Athens I believe has so much meaning for
us.
But there is much to learn from the similarities.
There's at least as much to learn from the differences between the Athenians and
ourselves although the Athenians valued wealth and material goods as we do.
They regarded economic life and status both as less noble and less important
than participation and distinction in public service to the community although
they were pioneers in recognizing the importance of autonomy and legitimate
claims of the individual they could not imagine the fulfillment of the
individual's spiritual needs.
Apart from his involvement in the life of a well ordered political community to
understand the achievement of Pericles and his contemporaries we just need to be
aware of these significant differences.
I think we ought to also study them with a certain humility for in spite of
their antiquity.
The ancient Athenians may have known and believed things.
We have either forgotten or never known and we ought to keep open the
possibility that in some respects they might have been right.
About some of these things
now what I've been talking about up to now is the workings of the Athenian
constitution for active citizens.
And I remind you that means three men adults.
Who have citizen parents that excludes a lot of people who lived in Athens.
And so I'd like to spend a little time also talking about two groups of such
people who were excluded from the political process women and slaves both of
which have caught the attention of modern scholars eager to demonstrate the
undemocratic aspects of ancient Athens when judged by our criteria which seem
more and more to require that every living creature.
I was going to sacred every living thing be treated with equality.
I know that of course there are feelings of people who want to say that and we
all say we all agree there should be no discrimination between men and women.
They of course should be no slaves.
But now we're moving towards saying that people should receive all of
citizenship or citizen rights who aren't.
Even legally citizens.
There are many people who want to give protections to animals that now are
limited to people.
And there are people also who want to include trees and other vegetation under
these protections.
So
we need to examine the Athenian situation and make our judgments about that.
Let's talk about women first.
Greek society like most cultures throughout history was dominated by men.
This was true of the Democratic city of Athens in the great days of Pericles no
less than in other Greek cities.
Nevertheless the position of women in classical Athens has been the subject of a
great deal of controversy.
The bulk of the evidence coming from the law.
The actual laws of Athens from philosophical and moral writings and from
information about the conditions of daily life and the organization of society
shows that women were excluded from most public aspects of I should.
But most aspects of public life.
They could not vote.
They could not take part in the political assemblies.
They could not hold public office or take any direct part in politics.
Male citizens of all classes had these public responsibilities and opportunities
the same sources show that in the private aspects of life women were always
under the control of a male guardian a father at first a husband later or
failing these and appropriate male relative designated by the law.
Women married young usually between the ages of 12 and 18.
I think if we think of them as being about 15 years old we'll probably have a
reasonable average
husbands on the other hand we're typically at least 30 and usually over it when
they married so that women were always in a relationship like that of a daughter
to a father.
When you think about the realities of life marriages furthermore were arranged
by the way as in other societies the higher you get in society the more likely
it is that these marriages will be arranged with economic considerations social
considerations predominate predominating as you get lower in society I can I can
only suspect because we don't really have evidence that it was far more informal
and maybe that marriages may have been as a consequence of the mutual desire
than was true for the upper classes.
Normally these I am shifting again to where we have evidence and that means
probably not the poorest women in the city.
The women normally had no choice of their husband the woman's dowry.
And dowries were required.
He was controlled by a male relative divorce was very difficult for a woman to
obtain for she needed the approval of a male relative who if he gave that
approval had then to be willing to serve as her guardian after the dissolution
of her marriage in case of divorce.
The dowry would be returned with the woman but it was still to be controlled.
In that case by her father were the appropriate male relative.
Excuse me
the main function and responsibility of a respectable Athenian woman of a
citizen family was to produce male heirs for the household of her husband.
If however her father's household lacked a male heir.
The daughter became what the Greeks called an epic.
Clara was the heiress.
To the family property.
In that case she was required by law to marry the man who was the next of kin to
her father's.
Saw on for on her father's side in order to produce the desired male offspring
in the Athenian way of thinking women were lent by one household to another for
purposes of bearing and raising a male heir to continue the existence of the oil
costs the family establishment
because the pure and legitimate lineage of the offspring was important.
Women were carefully segregated from man outside the family and were confined to
the women's quarters even in the house men might seek sexual gratification in
several ways outside the house with prostitutes of high or low style prostitutes
frequently recruited from abroad but respectable women stayed home to raise the
children cook.
Weave cloth and oversee the management of the household.
The only public function of women was an important one in the various rituals
and festivals of the state religion.
There is a very new book by a professor at NYU by the name of Connolly which
studies very carefully all the information that we know about ancient Greek
priestesses at which reveals.
I think something that we haven't known enough about before that women is in
that realm at least had an enormously important.
And I would say sort of Gloria's role in that way.
It doesn't change any of the things I've said about the other aspects of life.
But we we have had we've really not paid enough attention to this religious side
of things and we should remember that religion was very important for these
people even though to us it looks as though they were very secular in the way
they lived religion and their way of thinking was very important.
So anyway apart from these religious things Athenian women were expected to
remain home quiet and unnoticed.
Pericles told the widows and mothers of the Athenian men who died in the first
year of the Peloponnesian War.
Only this.
Know you will either have read or you will read Pericles famous funeral oration.
And he has all these things to say and at the very end he addresses the widows
and the mothers of the men who have died in a way that puzzles me beyond belief.
And I still don't understand why he chose to say what he did but what he said I
think was the common wisdom about what the situation was.
He said.
Your great glory is not to fall short of your natural character and the greatest
glory of women is to be least talked about by men.
Whether for good or ill
OK.
I.
That's what they thought.
Why the hell did he say it at the end of that fuel oration if anybody has any
insight on that.
I would be very grateful if you would tell me about it.
Not now or at any time in the future.
The picture derived from these sources is largely accurate but I would argue
that it does not fit in well.
With what we learn from the evidence of a wholly different set of sources.
First of all what we see in the pictorial art chiefly on these invasive
paintings and even more strikingly I think in what we learn from the tragedies
and the comedies that were performed every year at two great festivals in
Athens.
And finally these things are derived very much from the mythology which is after
all their religious tradition of the Athenians.
Now these sources often show women as central characters and powerful figures in
both the public and the private spheres the climate of mistrust who shows up in
Aeschylus as tragedy Agamemnon she arranges the murder of her royal husband and
establishes the tyranny of her lover whom she dominates.
Then there is the terrifying and powerful media of Euripides who negotiates with
kings and can commit horrible deeds in her fury which I think your reporting
suggests is very justified fury even if the deed is not so we are and these are
just two two examples of which there are many in which women are central and
important and powerful and active and not passive.
And it's all about them.
We are left with an apparent contradiction clearly revealed by a famous speech
and you repeat his tragedy media and I'd like to.
Read you that he presented his play at the diagnostic festival in Athens.
His heroine Madea is a foreign woman.
Who has unusual powers.
I mean she is practically something like a witch a sorceress don't imagine these
Halloween kind of witches a proper which is so beautiful that she can be which
you think of them.
So.
She is a farm one with these powers but in a speech that follows.
She describes the fate of women in terms that appear to give an accurate account
of the condition of women in fifth century B.C. Athens.
Here's what she says of all things which are living and can form a judgment.
We women are the most unfortunate creatures firstly with an excess of wealth.
It is required for us to buy a husband and take for our bodies a master for not
to take one is even worse and now the question is serious whether we take a good
or bad one.
For there is no easy escape for a woman nor can she say no to her marriage she
arrives among new modes of behavior and manners and she needs prophetic power
unless she has learned at home how best to manage him who shares the bed with
her and if we work out all this well and carefully and the husband lives with us
and lightly bears his yoke.
This life is enviable.
If not I'd rather die a man when he's tired of the company this home goes out of
the house and puts an end to his boredom and turns to a friend or companion of
his own age.
But we are forced to keep our eyes on one alone what they say of us is that we
have a peaceful time living at home while they do the fighting in war.
How wrong they are.
I would very much rather stand three times in the front of battle than to bear
one child.
I wonder what the Athenian men in that audience thought about all of that.
The picture that Medea paints of women subjected to men accords well of course
with much of the evidence.
But we have to take note of the fact that the woman who complains of women's lot
is the powerful central figure in a tragedy that is named after her.
By the way it's not the only case.
Another of the great tragedies of addict drama is Sophocles and Tiffany and then
taking he is another heroic woman who defies kings and everybody else in order
to do the right thing and who accepts death.
Rather than to give way in her principles.
This is not the kind of a woman that Pericles had in mind when he said just shut
up and be sure nobody is talking about you.
Now this.
Tragedy was produced.
We need to remember at state expense before most of the Athenian population and
was written by a man.
Who was one of Athens greatest poets and dramatists media is a cause of terror
to the audience and at the same time an object of their pity and sympathy as a
victim of injustice.
She is anything but the creature least talked about by men whether for good or
for bad.
When those men walked out of that theater they would be talking about media for
the next week.
There is reason to believe that the role played by Athenian women may have been
more complex than their legal status might suggest.
And that's all I feel I can say about that subject because I haven't been able
to resolve the contradiction
most.
Yeah.
I mean well I won't.
I won't go into modern scholarly arguments but let me just say that no matter
what they all say no matter how they come out this dichotomy is there.
It's in the sources we need to do some thinking in some supplying for things
that are missing.
If we are to comprehend how both halves of this can be true as I'm sure they
both are somehow
let's turn next to the question of slavery.
In Greece chattel slavery proper began to increase about 500 B.C. and it
remained an important element in society.
The main sources of slaves were war captives.
And the captives of pirates who made a living in large part by catching people
and selling them as slaves.
And of course those people at first enslaved through war piracy or other means
who were sold by slave traders.
They did not unlike in the American South.
Were they successful or necessarily did they try to breed slaves themselves they
were typically bought from slave traders
like the Chinese the Egyptians and almost every other civilized people in the
ancient world.
The Greeks regarded foreigners as inferiors they call them barbarians because
they uttered words that sounded to the Greeks like bah bah bah bah bah
and most slaves working for the Greeks were foreigners Greek sometimes enslaved
Greeks but typically not to serve in the Greek home as a servant or
even in a debt really not so much at home.
They did use slaves as I've told you earlier to work on the farms alongside the
farmers.
The chief occupation as always before the 20th century was agriculture the great
majority of Greek farmers work these small holdings too poor to support even one
slave.
Some would be so fortunate as to have as many as one or two slaves to work
alongside.
I think as I said earlier I think probably most of the hot lights could manage
that but I think we don't we really don't know the answer to that.
I'm sure they range from zero to more than two but if you're thinking one or two
you're probably right.
The upper classes had larger farms of course that would be let out to free
tenant farmers or worked by slaves generally under an overseer who was himself a
slave.
Large landowners generally did not have one single great state in every way I
want you to try to get out of your head.
The picture of slavery in the American South with its plantations and great
squads of slaves in one place under one master that it was not the typical way
for the Greeks but rather the wealthy would have several smaller farms scattered
about the polls.
Well that arrangement did not encourage the amassing of these great hordes of
agricultural slaves who would later work the cotton and sugar plantations of the
new world.
Slaves were used in larger numbers in what I laughingly call industry in the
ancient world I mean handicrafts but one exception to that typical system was
mining.
We know something about the mines in southern Athens where the silver was found
and that reveals a different picture.
Nick is a wealthy Athenian of the fifth century B.C. owned a thousand slaves
whom he rented to a mining contractor for a profit.
But this is actually this is unique.
We don't know of anything like this besides this situation and it's by far the
largest number of slaves that we know any individual hill in another instance of
large slave holdings in Athens a family of resident aliens employed about a
hundred and twenty slaves in their shield factory.
That was the military industrial complex in Athens.
Most manufacturing however was at very small scale with shops using one or two
or a handful of slaves slaves worked as craftsmen in almost every trade and it
was true for the agricultural slaves on small farms.
They worked alongside their masters
if you took these slaves that I regard as taking care of the majority of the
work in Athens.
If you transfer later them into being handy men or regular workers who worked at
jobs regularly who were free.
You would if you went in you wouldn't into these shops.
That's what you would think because you didn't have somebody lashing anybody
over great numbers of people you would have two or three guys working there.
One would be the guy who owns it and the other two guys would be slaves.
A significant proportion of slaves of course were domestic servants and many
were shepherds publicly held slaves also served as policemen.
Don't get carried away.
There were very very few policemen.
They were also prison attendants.
They were very very few prisoners and very few prisoners.
They were clerks and there were secretaries and some of them worked their way up
because of their natural skills whether if they were in work.
This was usually the case.
If you found such people in commerce and most especially in banking we hear that
one of the richest men in Athens in the fourth century was a man called paisan
who had been a slave and by his talents had bought his own freedom and had then
become one of the richest men in Athens.
That's an oddball story.
Don't take that as being very widespread but it shows you one element in the
system.
The number of slaves in ancient Greece is a subject of continuing controversy
and that's because we don't have the kind of evidence to come to a conclusive
answer.
There are no useful figures for the absolute number of slaves or for their
percentage of the free population in any city except Athens there.
The evidence permits estimates for the slave population in the classical period
by which I mean the 5th and the 4th centuries that ranged from a low of twenty
thousand slaves to a high of about one hundred thousand slaves if we accept the
mean between these extremes.
I love to do that when I don't have any better thing to do.
You come up with sixty thousand slaves now the estimates that are made about the
free population of Athens in the same period at its height.
Some people would say as low as not nobody gets much below 40000 households.
Some want to move it up towards about 60000 households.
What do I come up with.
Right.
Fifty thousand that would yield a figure of fewer than two slaves per family.
It has been estimated that only a quarter to a third of free Athenians owned any
slaves at all.
So the distribution was on what was unequal with most families having no slaves.
And some families having many some historians have noted that in the American
South in the period before the Civil War where slaves also made up less than a
third of the total population and three quarters of free Southerners had no
slaves.
The proportion of slaves to free citizens was similar to that in ancient Athens
because slavery was so important to the economy of the South.
These historians suggest it may have been equally important and similarly
oppressive.
In ancient Athens I find several problems with this analogy.
For one thing it's important to make a distinction between a world such as the
Cotton States of the American South for a civil war.
Where a single cash crop well suited for exploitation by large groups of slaves
dominates the economy and a society like the one in Athens where the economy was
mixed the crops varied the land and its distribution very poorly suited to
massive slavery another major differences in the likelihood of a slave achieving
freedom the freeing of American slaves although it happened was comparatively
rare but in Greece it was very common.
The most famous example I've told you already about pays you know began as a
bank clerk and his freedom became Athens Rich's banker and then was even
rewarded with Athenian citizenship.
But that's very rare.
On the other hand the acquisition of freedom by slaves was not.
People frequently free their slaves on their own death and often before that for
various reasons.
It's also important to distinguish the American South where the slaves were
distinguished from their masters by skin color.
Where the masters were increasingly hostile to the idea of freeing slaves and in
terror of slave rebellions with a very different society of classical half their
slaves walk the streets with such ease as to offend noblemen who were class
conscious.
Plato complain about the Athenian democracy that men and women who have been
sold are no less free than their purchasers and an anonymous writer of the fifth
century was appalled by the behavior of slaves in Athens.
He says one may not strike them their nor will a slave.
Step aside for you.
And if it were legal for a free man to strike a slave.
And Athenian would often have been struck under the mistaken impression that he
was a slave.
For the clothing of the common people there is no way superior to that of the
slaves and the resident aliens.
Nor is their appearance.
They allow slaves there to live in luxury and some of them in considerable
magnificence in a state relying on naval power.
It is inevitable that slaves must work for hire so that we may take profits from
what they earn.
While there are rich slaves it is no longer profitable for my slave to be afraid
of you.
In Sparta my slave would be afraid of you but there in Athens if your slave is
afraid of me he will probably spend some of his own money to free himself from
danger this then is why in the matter of free speech we have put slaves and free
men on equal terms.
Now a lot of this is absolute baloney.
This is some right wing character who is just so annoyed with Athenian democracy
that he is making over-the-top statements but it cannot be so far removed from
reality as to be ridiculous.
Or else it wouldn't be in any way persuasive.
So I think we have to imagine slaves moved about Athens with a degree of ease
and security and has as he rightly must rightly be saying you really couldn't
tell a slave from a free man very readily in ancient Athens that all of this is
meant to be.
By contrast with the picture of the South
even more remarkable the Athenians were on occasion willing to contemplate the
liberation of all their slaves.
In 4 0 6 their city facing defeat in the Peloponnesian War.
They freed all slaves of military age and granted citizenship to those who rode
the ships that won the battle of Argosy twice more at crucial moments.
Similar proposals were made although without success now during the Civil War
people did suggest to the south that they liberate their slaves and enroll them
in the Southern army.
And such ideas were always quashed and I think we can read something very
important into the difference between the two situations the southern the
Southerners were afraid to do it because they didn't trust the slaves not to
turn on them and kill them if they were armed.
The Athenians just didn't have that fear at all.
And I think that's a big story about the difference between the two system
okay.
That's all I have to say about these subjects.
We do have six seven eight minutes I'd be delighted to respond to any comments
or questions.
And if you would like to put about any of these topics.
Yes
did not fear this life because I think in the first place they they did not
treat them so harshly as to create that kind of absolute hatred that nothing
could take care of.
Second of all I think because the prospect of their liberation being not an out
of the question idea soften the edge between master and slave to a degree where
the Athenians didn't have that sense these people are waiting to kill me.
I guess another thing is since so many of them first of all you start with
household slaves.
Well even in the south.
There were very very few household slaves who did not develop.
Friendly and warm feelings towards the people in the house so that takes care of
another situation.
And then there were all these slaves who worked side by side with their master
not as part of a gang under an overseer but as a fellow worker with their
farmers.
So the whole way of thinking about it I think was so different that we never
hear.
And here's another thing we never hear of a slave rebellion among the polis of
Athens.
We do hear of Hell OK rebellions of course it doesn't fit that mold in Sparta
but we never hear of a slave rebellion in spite of all the troubles these towns
and I think those would be the reasons I think us.
Well what when they had skills.
This happened in the south too by the way.
Just not to the same extent when they had skills.
It was in the Master's interest to encourage them to do their work to the best
of their ability.
And so they rewarded them by letting them keep part of the profits of what they
produced.
And it was that of course which allowed some of these people to buy their own
freedom.
It is true that that happened in the south as well.
Anything else.
Yes ma'am.
It's the answer is I'm sure there must have been runaway slave but it's just a
non issue so far as we can see you know it's the big deal in the south in the
north when fugitive slave laws become a great source of trouble.
But I think there was not too much running away of slaves because there really
wasn't any place to run to.
There was no place where there wasn't slavery.
So if an Athenian slave runs to be Osama he's gonna be a big ocean slave.
I think that was one of the reasons and they put that together with the rather
gentle arrangements I've described.
The combination I think reduced the problem of runaway slave anything else.
Yes.
The Spartan situation as compared to the Athenian situation.
Night and day.
The hell.
I've told you all about it.
You've read all about it and as.
A man leading a rebellion and in spite of the beginning of the fourth century
said about hell lots and other people who were not Sparta gates in in less a
demon they would have gladly eaten the Spartans raw so that's there it is.
That's all you need to know about the difference.
Yes.
Too badly
I don't know.
How does the British system work.
Do they do that.
I've told this story to various American lawyers and law professors and I've
been struck by their absolute lack of imagination.
But but apart from when I finally get them to think about these things they tell
me some of them tell me very happily that in some areas we are moving towards
that or we have some of that.
They tell me that in civil cases very often the arrangement that they agree to
is that one side will make one proposal the other will make another proposal and
some arbiter.
Will choose between the two.
But mostly if I speak to especially law professors I I've tried to get them to
think about the advantages and disadvantages of the Athenian system with some
objectivity and I and I say to them you put aside for the moment the question of
whether you think justice is more likely to be arrived at through the Anglo
Saxon system of law or the Athenian system of law.
Because the truth is we don't know whether one way or the other.
And I found that they can't do it.
They're so committed to the conviction that justice is only possible under the
Anglo Saxon system of advocacy and competition and all of those things that they
just won't think about.
But you of course although three quarters and you're going to become lawyers
anyway
you're above that you'll be much more judicious in thinking about.
Do I have to make an announcement.
Yes those of you who were good enough to serve as hub lights in our
demonstration.
It turns out we need for you to say it's okay for your pictures to appear on
these deathless productions that we're engaged in now.
So would you if you could please come up forward and speak with John Lee and
he'll talk to you about what has to happen.
Thanks very much.